what's going on everybody welcome to
another Q&A in this Q&A we're gonna
start off by talking about bitcoins so
Bitcoin has been blowing up in terms of
popularity and price and I have been
getting phone calls and emails and texts
and contact from friends of friends and
friends and family and all this kind of
stuff and people were like should I
invest in Bitcoin and I'm like if you
could do the research and so just like
with anything you should understand what
you're investing into if you can't
understand it no you should not invest
into it then you're just blind so with
Bitcoin you know so some people were
asking do I even own Bitcoin and stuff
like this and I've been in Bitcoin I've
owned Bitcoin since 2013 and I followed
it prior to 2013 my main concern with
Bitcoin back then was that the core of
Bitcoin to me the the production of
Bitcoin was flawed so a lot of people I
knew I was looking into mining Bitcoin
and a lot of people I knew were mining
Bitcoin and after doing the research it
was clear to me people who were mining
Bitcoin and making a profit were
actually thieves they were stealing
electricity either from their parents
their dorms something like that the
people who work thieves weren't making
money mining histo said to me I was like
oh this is probably never gonna work
because nobody can actually mine Bitcoin
profitably without stealing electricity
so that was my main concern but and then
also there wasn't really any use cases
yet for Bitcoin people weren't really
transacting there are a few things from
time to time but it was very rare so
then around 2013 I started to see that
well first of all companies were getting
into Bitcoin not to sell mining rigs but
actually just to produce mining
equipment for themselves mine Bitcoin
saw the Bitcoin and profit and that was
a very good signal to me that was set
okay now it's legit the mining process
is legit but I also realized the value
of Bitcoin isn't really necessarily you
know the the core of Bitcoin isn't
mining Bitcoin that's not true the core
of Bitcoin is the blockchain network and
so once I realized I was like okay okay
this is it's different I was looking at
in terms of you know mining Bitcoin and
trading Bitcoin and all that that's not
quite where the value is
so so that was that was when I got into
Bitcoin and then I actually started
doing automated trading of Bitcoin in
the markets because the markets were so
volatile there was a lot of money to be
made there especially in it when I first
got started and then as time went on I
started trading for other clients and
stuff like that and I actually did that
for quite some time and I stopped doing
that though because people are people I
guess and so the main issue I had there
was so for anybody who stuck with it for
a long period of time so because because
basically at least what we were doing
was a grid strategy which might mean
nothing to you but basically you would
sell as price would rise and then you
would buy back his price would fall and
so you would just keep doing this even
with little changes like little ups and
downs but also big ups and downs and
over a long period of time that would
make money but over a short period of
time what was problematic was as Bitcoin
would rise the clients would pour more
money into the accounts so in effect
what they were doing was buying the
highs and then as Bitcoin will fall they
would lose their minds and they would
sell Bitcoin so in fact locking in the
lows and so so and then what would
happen is a long enough time line people
would you know I you would keep having
to adjust the start time of the
performance of the account and then
people would be like oh we're losing
we're not beating the market what's
going on and I'm like well you're buying
high and selling low and and so that was
really annoying to have to explain to
people over and over and over and when I
finally stopped taking clients from the
beginning to the end
I think price started around like 600 or
something like that and then at the end
it was like a little over a thousand and
and I just went through the entire thing
and it was like anybody who's stuck from
the beginning to the end made a lot of
money they beat the market but the
problem was people are people they buy
high and they sell low so they're just
irrational so I stopped doing that I
found that to be very stressful and just
not all that enjoyable so I don't do
that anymore
so anyways then I I kind of lost my
interest in Bitcoin around 2015-2016
because fees got really high so you
couldn't transfer like a hundred dollars
without paying like a
eight to ten percent fee and also it
would take a while so it was like well
why wouldn't we use PayPal or if we
wanted to move a large amount of money
we would just do a wire transfer and so
so again that just I kind of started
losing faith in Bitcoin because the use
case was going away also not only just
you know quick transactions and low fees
was going away but also centralization
was happening both in terms of banking
mining and really also exchanges in
general so there's only a handful of
exchanges that are being used now
there's only really a handful of banks
and really arguably like two banks right
maybe three maybe three like maybe maybe
bitstamp coinbase and blockchain dot
info or something like that I'm sure
there are you can find graphs online
like who has the the majority holds and
anyway it's very centralized and then
with mining it's all in China and so
with all this centralization it's it's
again I'm starting to see like I'm not
sure about this anymore but at least in
terms of transaction speed and fees the
Lightning Network update - - Bitcoin is
set to kind of fix that so historically
litecoin has been the the quicker and
cheaper way to transact Bitcoin like
litecoin is the the silver and a
bitcoins gold as you might hear and so
so litecoin did have a purpose up into
till the Lightning Network and now the
reason why litecoin is rising is my
guess would be that people get on these
exchanges and they're like Oh bitcoin is
sixteen thousand dollars I don't want to
buy that but litecoin it's only two
hundred or three hundred dollars I'll
buy that and I think that's what caused
that to go crazy I don't think like
coins gonna hold but we'll see and then
there's a theorem of course I'll just
bring these over - so one thing I wanted
to point out too is like the high for
Bitcoin on coinbase was 19 340 but if
you look at the other exchanges like
BitFenix it was 17 - so at - over $2,000
discrepancy that's because people were
going to coin base and just buying on
coinbase because coin base is an easy
exchange to get on - and by Bitcoin
that's where you're seeing that 2000
dollar difference
that's a big deal and that just tells me
a lot of probably uneducated investors
just got into Bitcoin there and that
presents a pretty substantial risk
because they're just it's easy come easy
go for a lot of people so I feel like if
Bitcoin was to hit like 14 or even 13
thousand there's gonna be a P an ik for
sure but you know whatever
so anyway yes so then we have a theorem
which does have a use case but it
appears that use case is making a lot of
money really fast in scamming clients so
so with the I cos it's a cool use case
it's a cool idea but it unfortunately
people are just super greedy and and I
think I'm not sure that's gonna pan out
very well but we'll see I mean people
say the same thing about the Internet it
was mostly scammers and and that kind of
stuff so in a word that I probably can't
use cuz I'm gonna get D monetized but
we'll talk about it later
anyway so with aetherium
like I was contact I get kind of at
least weekly but usually multiple times
a week by some IC o----
some company that's one to have an IC
o---- and they don't they're like they
just want me on the team they don't talk
about the product really or what I'd be
doing all they talk about is the IC
o---- how much money I'm gonna make in
the IC o---- and I'm just like clearly
that's all you care about and so yeah
dangerous for sure for sure
and then of course like I said litecoin
I think this is just people panic buying
because they don't want to buy a whole
Bitcoin and they think for whatever
reason they need to buy a whole Bitcoin
or a whole coin at a time which
obviously you don't anyway yeah so
that's my answer on Bitcoin the other
question is that people were asking was
on ad pocalypse have I been affected yes
I've been affected historically it
hasn't been too too bad for me ad rates
like on the GTA series were like one
twentieth of the typical ad rate just
because it was self-driving cars in GTA
and that just tanked my ad rate for that
serious which was unfortunate but I
didn't want to change what we were doing
it in and also I mean that was where it
was supposed to be like Grand Theft Auto
is a great environment for AI so anyway
that was frustrating and so yeah I feel
like that was somewhat impactful but
what
and then I was pretty much okay until
very very recently my last three videos
in a row I've just been Bam Bam Bam Bam
just demonetised I have no idea why it's
super annoying and it's been yeah
chatbot number eight the last QA and
then chap out number nine all
demonetised
pretty much instantly but it's weird
because sometimes you'll upload the
video and it's monetized for like five
to ten hours and then BAM do you
monetize and then other times you'll
upload BAM it's demonetised immediately
and then other times it might be two
three hours or whatever so anyway it's
it's super inconsistent and their
suggestion to you is well upload it as
unlisted and then I guess wait five to
ten hours at least before you I would
say probably wait 24 hours before you
actually publish it publicly but to me I
just I feel like that's so backwards and
like what about the people who are like
a news channel or product review where
like it's really important that you're
like the first or one of the first
otherwise you're just you're you're not
gonna you're not gonna rank and so like
that really that sucks and solely like
what I don't understand is well okay
what about like why not channels who
have I don't I don't know pick a number
ten thousand subs a hundred thousand
subs a million subs I don't know pick a
number and give them the benefit of the
doubt so when I upload a video if I say
this is good for it's not gonna be it if
I say this is suitable for advertisers
I mean it's suitable for advertisers so
when you de monetize my video the first
thing I'm going to do is request a
manual review so why not flip it around
if somebody uploads a video and it says
it's suitable for advertisers but you're
out your stupid algorithm thinks oh our
captions which are we know their
captions are super flawed like I've seen
so many examples where the caption
thinks I've said some crazy stuff and I
don't have a crazy accent or anything
like that so to me it's like your
caption going off your captions which
they're pretty they haven't really come
out and said exactly all the things that
they're doing to detect a video and why
it might be D monetizable or bad or not
suitable but we're pretty sure it's
captions title description and
keywords stuff like that seems to be
coming into it and you know but their
captions are so flawed they're not even
good captions
it's like anyway so so why not with it
with so say for me when I upload a video
and I say yes monetize this video I'm
saying I'm giving you my word it's
suitable right and if your algorithm
detects that oh something's wrong okay
do a manual review don't remove the
monetization status do a manual review
because if you de monetize my video the
first thing I'm gonna do is hit uh
request a manual review which by the way
can take up to seven days so so why not
just reverse that and then have like a
three-strike system so again you don't
you wouldn't do this for every user
account you would do it for the user
accounts with ten thousand hundred
thousand whatever subs or view number
you want but you know someone with
something to lose and then have a
three-strike system if they violate it
and you say no this really is not
suitable for most advertisers okay give
them a strike right and then eventually
you can remove their youtube partnership
after three strikes or something like
that where this way
people aren't losing that initial boost
of views that they would otherwise be
able to have both in terms of releasing
on time and then if they do decide that
okay well this is really a newsworthy
event I need to release it right now
they're not gonna lose that boosted
views and/or the boost of ad revenue so
like for me and my channel I mean it
sucks it's annoying but it's not really
a big deal because like 99.9% of all my
views come from older videos they come
from videos even from years ago and so
it hasn't really it's just mostly been
annoying and tedious for me and now when
I like I used to just upload videos and
like whenever I was done recording I'd
upload boom hit publish but now I can't
do that I have to upload to unlisted and
then wait 5 to 10 hours and then hit
request to manual review and then every
few hours or whatever I'd have to check
did he get reviewed yet right because
the other thing too is they don't email
you they don't notify you when it's been
D monetized they don't notify you when
it's been remodeled
now they're just so it's so black box
and hidden from you and secret it's like
I don't know it's very unfriendly it's
it's it's not the right way to go about
it so anyway that's my thoughts on ad
pocalypse and being demonetised again
it's not even really that negatively
impacting me but I can I can only
imagine what it's like for people that
are like running any sort of news
channel or current events or products
and there's probably a bunch of others
are like a vlog I mean I guess you could
you could push your vlog out one day
beyond or whatever but again like all
that kind of stuff it's like man you're
that's a lot of people that are being an
if it if there's unlucky as I am like it
just seems like every video I'm putting
out now is is going to be demonetised
I'm curious when I put this one up if
it'll be Auto demonetized but anyway
that's all for now if you guys have more
questions whatever feel free to leave
them below otherwise I will see you in
another video